imagine an entire network of flying cars
zooming around at 2,000 meters above our
ingested city streets your morning
commute would be a lot different up
there you could travel at higher speeds
and you could reach almost any remote
destination but what kind of laws would
we have to put in place to control the
skies how could we enforce those laws
and how would we deal with the danger of
car crashes in the sky this is what if
and here's what would happen if we had
flying cars the idea of flying cars has
been around for almost as long as the
car has and with most people imagining
that the future will include some form
of flying vehicle we seem to have
accepted that flying cars will
eventually become reality but do we need
them the companies that are currently
producing them would say yes obviously
because they'd be much more
environmentally friendly than our
current gas guzzling automobiles but
other scientists say that we just be
replacing one environmental catastrophe
with another now before we get too
carried away with the environmental
impacts of flying cars let's figure out
if it's even possible to fill our skies
with them several companies have already
produced working models so we know that
it's physically possible but making them
a regular part of our society would be
much more complicated for starters
there's the question of who'd be driving
them would it be us or some kind of
artificial intelligence
according to aviation safety magazine
human error is the cause of 90% of
non-commercial plane accidents this is
one of the reasons why many experts
think that flying cars would need to be
autonomous in other words humans would
not drive them studies also show that
accidents are much more likely when
humans are behind the wheel of the
ordinary cars we have now and remember
that up in the air accidents would be a
lot more destructive not only would
there be high-speed collisions but there
would be the collateral damage of the
wrecks falling to the ground or crashing
into surrounding buildings everyday
normal car issues that we experience on
the ground would also be a lot more
problematic in the air if your engine
breaks down or you happen to run out of
gas completely you can still pull over
to the side of the road
you just have to plummet for 2,000
meters before you crash there bad
weather would also become a much bigger
problem on your airborne journeys as
conditions like strong winds could throw
your flying car off course and possibly
into a tailspin maybe that would have to
be rules in place for when a flying
vehicle could and could not be used
because of mother nature and we'd need
police up there to enforce those rules
along with other laws regarding speed
and allowed elevation hikes but how
would a cop pull someone over in midair
okay so clearly there would be a lot of
work to do to integrate flying cars into
our society but it'd all be for the good
of the environment right it is estimated
that an electric flying vehicle could be
thirty five percent more energy
efficient over a 100 kilometer trip when
compared to a gas powered car but as
impressive as this is it doesn't top
what an electric vehicle is currently
capable of achieving on top of that
although we'd be eliminating the
problematic gasoline's needed for
conventional cars mining the natural
elements required for our flying cars
rechargeable batteries would be just
about as bad
so maybe flying cars will never be
convenient enough for the average
commuter to rely on but that doesn't
mean we should stop exploring the
technology maybe the ideas behind flying
cars could lead to bigger and better
advancements down the road but that's a
topic for another what-if
[Music]